翻訳: Natsuki NAKAMURA
校正: Koichiro YODA
こんにちは
​​東京大学の鳴海拓志と申します
私はバーチャルリアリティの
​研究をしています
バーチャルリアリティというとですね
こういうイメージかなと思います
「ヘッドマウントディスプレイ」と呼ばれる
頭につけるようなディスプレイを装着して
全然この現実とは違う世界に行って
何か楽しんで帰ってくると
エンターテインメントとか
そういうイメージがありますよね
で 実際にですね
こういう家庭用のゲーム機で使える
ヘッドマウントディスプレイが売り出されたり
1,000円で買えるダンボールの
ヘッドマウントディスプレイが
売り出されたりとか
かなり そろそろ普及してきているのかな
と思っています
2016年ぐらいには
バーチャルリアリティ元年みたいなことが
結構ニュースなんかでも
話題になったと思います
この中でバーチャルリアリティ
聞いたことある方
どれくらいいらっしゃいますか？
まあ ほとんどもう みなさん
馴染みのものになってきていると思います
「こんなに馴染んでいたら
もう研究者って何にも
やることないんじゃないの？」って
たまに意地悪なことを言われます
で じゃあ 僕らが何をやっているか
っていうところから
ちょっと話していきたいんですが
僕らはVRを通じて自分の内面を知って
​​さらにそれを変えていくというような
研究をしています ​​
で その前にですね
その基盤的な技術として
「どうやって今のバーチャルリアリティの
限界を突破することができるか」
ということを考えています
たとえば ゲームをプレイする時
こういうふうに座ってプレイして
自分の身体で動き回ることができません
で この限界を突破したい時に
​どういうことができるかということを
一つ紹介したいと思います
なぜ歩けないかというとですね
たとえば 歩いた時に
人の身体を追いかける装置があれば
バーチャルリアリティの中で
動けるんですけれど
実際にそれをやろうとすると
体験したい空間と同じ大きさの部屋が
必要になってきます
もしみなさんのご家庭で
すごく広い街 たとえば神戸の街を
VRで再現しました というのを
歩いて体験できるようにしようとしても
おそらく皆さんの家庭だと
壁にぶつかってしまいます
もしかしたら 皆さん
大富豪かもしれないので
とても広いお家を
お持ちかもしれないですが
一般家庭ではやっぱり
３メートル×３メートルぐらいしか
動けなくて
それ以上行こうとすると
壁に当たってしまう
そこで考えたのがこういうシステムです
図にあるように壁が曲がっています
でも ヘッドマウントディスプレイを
掛けた人には真っ直ぐな壁が見えている
で この壁を触ろうとすると
​実際に曲がった壁があるので
触れることができるわけです
そうすると「​​あれ？ここに
真っ直ぐな壁があるぞ？」と思う
こういう状況です
で 真っ直ぐな壁に触れながら
真っ直ぐに見える壁に触れながら
実際には曲がった壁の周りを
ぐるぐる回っているんですが
この人は 真っ直ぐな壁を見て
触ったらそこに（壁が）あるから
「絶対真っ直ぐな壁だ」と信じていて
歩くと真っ直ぐ歩いているように
感じてしまう
ということが分かります
で 実はこれ 直径６メートルのところを
ぐるぐるしているだけなんですが
この人は無限に真っ直ぐ
歩いているような感覚を
得ることができるわけです
我々が現実を感じる時に
空間っていうのがどういうふうに
構成されているかっていうと
実際に体を使って歩いた感覚よりも
目で見て信じているとか
触って信じていることがすごく強いので
こういうことが起こるのだ
ということが分かってきました
もう一つ 例を挙げてみましょう
これは味を変える装置です
と言っても 食べ物は変わらないんですね
どういう装置かというと
このゴーグルを通して見ると
普通のクッキーがですね
いきなりチョコレートのクッキーに変わる
見た目が変わるだけじゃなくて
ちょっとこれ ごつい装置になっていますが
香りを出す装置が付いています
チョコレートの見た目で
チョコレートの香りを感じながら食べると
この人は味がチョコレートに
感じてしまう訳です
大体８割とか８割５分ぐらいの人が
そういうふうに感じてしまいます
もちろん 匂いと見た目の組合せは
好きに変えられるので
全く同じものを食べているのに
急にアーモンドクッキーになったり
ストロベリークッキーになったり
そういうことができます
そうすると たとえば
病院食がおいしくなったり
塩分を抑えて塩気が強いとか
そういうこともできるようになりますよね
で こういうふうに
実は 味っていうのは
舌で感じているものだけではなくて
鼻や目で感じている
もちろん盛付けみたいなのも
すごく料理に大事ですけれど
そういうところを考えてみると
味を簡単に出すことができる
ということが分かってきます
こういうことができるのは
なぜかというと
五感って 教科書レベルでは
セパレートして 独立したものだと
習っていると思うのですが
実際には 感覚の垣根を越えて
お互いに​​影響し合っている
からなんですね
最近の脳科学とか
認知科学の研究のおかげで
こういう影響が結構強いんだ​​
ということが分かってきました
こういう感覚の垣根を越えて
お互いに影響し合っていることを
「クロスモーダル知覚」といいます
特によく起こる組合せ同士の
感覚っていうのは
すごく結びつきが深くなっていく
なので「見た目がチョコレートで
香りがチョコレートだよね」ってなったら
もう脳がそこで複雑な処理をするよりも
「もう味がチョコレートが来るに
決まってるよね」って想像をして
それで補ってしまう
ということが起こります
なので ​​こういう現象を
使ってあげるとですね
出すのが難しい感覚でも
意外と簡単に出せたりする
ということが分かってきます
なので 我々の感覚って
結構あやふやなんですけれど
そこを突いてあげると
VRで色々なことができるというわけです
もう１個 例を紹介してみましょう
これはですね 「拡張満腹感」と
呼んでいるんですけれど
どういうものかっていうと
物を食べようとすると
食べ物が大きく見えます
大きく見える状態で食べると
お腹いっぱいにすぐなる
まあ すごい安直な研究ですよね
これがですね 実際にどれぐらい効くか
学生さんに「おやつ食べ放題の実験が
あるんだけど来る？」って言ったら
みんな喜んで来てくれるんですね
「そんな夢みたいな実験
あるんですか？」って
まあ実際にはですね ３日間できるだけ
コンディションを​​整えてもらって
同じような状態で食べて貰うんですけれど
この時に たとえばこの子は
「小さいと13枚 普通の時11枚で
大きいと もう７枚でお腹一杯になっちゃう」
ということが分かりました
なので この子は結構効きやすい子
だったんですけれど
いっぱい被験者を取ってみると
アベレージでプラスマイナス10％ぐらい
食べる量を変えることができます
で 被験者の人に「どれぐらい
食べる量を変えましたか​​？」って聞くと
「いや 変えてないですよ？」と
「だって 実験では 同じだけ
満足感が得られるまで
同じぐらい満腹になるまで食べて下さいと
指示されてるじゃないですか？」
と言っているわけで 本人は無意識に
食べる量を変えているわけです
なので ある意味ではこれは
無意識にダイエットする方法なわけですね
で なぜこういう事が起こるかというと
我々はお腹にバネ秤が
付いているわけじゃないので
何グラム食べましたとか​​分からないんで
その手掛りを​​見た目から得ているわけです
なので 見た目を変えるだけで
我々はどれくらいお腹いっぱいになるとか
どれくらい食べるっていう感覚とか
行動が変わってしまうというわけですね
なので こういう感覚の影響を
使ってあげると
我々は 実際に振る舞いを変えて
食生活を改めることが
できるようになるかもしれない
もうちょっと 考えてみると
そういう感覚の影響っていうのが
だんだん自分にも返ってくる
ということが分かってきます
で たとえば
さっきまでの話っていうのは
自分の外にある物の見え方を変えていました
じゃあ 次は 自分の見え方を
変えたらどうなるでしょう
そういう研究をちょっとやってみた例が
この「扇情的な鏡」という研究です
どういう研究かというと
鏡のように見えるんですけれど
実際には そこに映し出されているのは
自分の今の顔と ちょっと違う顔が
映っているんです
少しだけ口角が上がって笑顔になっていたり
少しだけ眉が下がって悲しい顔に見える
その時にどうなるかというと
鏡に映った顔に引きずられて
感情が変わっていくんです
鏡の中の自分が笑っていると
それに引きずられて
自分もどんどん楽しくなっていく
逆にちょっと悲しい顔を見ていると
ちょっと悲しい気分になったりする
で こういうふうにですね
実は 自分がどう見えているか
ということを利用してあげると
自分の感情をコントロールすることができる
もちろん使い方を誤ると怖いですけれど
もしかすると上手く自分の感情と付き合って
いくことができるようになるかもしれない
たとえば 「ちょっと落ち込んだ時に
明るい気分にしてあげる」
と​​いうようなことのために
こういうものが使えると思っています
で なぜこの文脈でこれを紹介したかというと
実は これをビデオチャットで使う
ということを考えてみました
皆さん もしかしたら
遠隔地の人とお仕事をされる時に
ビデオチャットみたいなものを
使うことがあるかもしれません
で 大体ですね ビデオチャットで話しても
「なんかリアルで会った方が良かったな」
ってなるわけですけれど
ここではちょっと変なことをやります
お互い２人でアイデアを出す
ブレインストーミングをやるんですが
普通にアイデアを出すと
東大生を呼びつけて
「５分でいっぱいアイデアを出してね」
って言うと大体８つくらい出るんですね
で その後にですね
お互いが笑顔に見えるように
さっきの技術を使ってあげます
そうすると それだけで
なんとアイデアが出る数が
12個なので1.5倍になったんです
つまり なんかポジティブな状況で
人と接するだけで
我々はクリエイティブになるわけですね
「勉強しなくてもいい
我々のパワーが出せる」
ということが分かってきました
なので こういうふうに
コミュニケーションの中で
「自分がどう見えるか？」とか
「相手からどう受け取られているか？」
っていう印象を変えてあげるってことを
VRの技術みたいなものを
応用してあげることによって
我々はもっと能力が引き出せる環境を
作れるということを確かめています
［分身で同調圧力を低減する］
ちょっと こういう研究について
もう１個事例を紹介してみましょう
さっきのは自分の見た目を
変えるということで
ある意味では変身を扱った研究ですが
今度は分身を扱った研究です
たとえば みんなで話し合いをして
何か答えを出さないといけない
シチュエーションというのがあります
たとえば ここに書いてあるのは
「砂漠遭難課題」と呼ばれているんですけど
砂漠で飛行機が落ちました と
「あなたたち もう手にいっぱい
荷物があるので１個しか持っていけません
ヘルメットか サングラスか マスク
どれか１個選んで下さい
皆さんで話し合って１個決めて下さい」
って言った時に
２人が最初に「サングラス」って言った後に
「ヘルメット」って
なかなか切り出しにくいですよね
もしくは 切り出した時に
「みんなサングラスって言ってるんだから
ちゃんとサングラスって言えよ」みたいな
圧力が掛かってしまうわけです
こういうのを同調圧力と呼んでいて
日本だと結構強いというふうに
言われていますよね
でも 本当は冷静に議論して欲しい
ヘルメットもいいところが
あるかもしれないので
ちゃんとそれをみんなが
納得した上で決めたい
なので こういう同調圧力を
なんとか低減できないかなと思いました
そこで さっきの影分身です
これは人数が２対１だから
いけないんですよね
この１人の人が２人に
なっちゃえば良いんです
かなり安直な方法ですけれど
こういうのを作りました
「こちらは擬似同調効果生成システムの
動作のデモ動画です」
「このように発言と発言の間の無音に従って
発言音声​​を２つに分割します」
「それを２体のアバターに
交互に喋らせることで
１人の話者を２人に見せかけます」
「こうすることで擬似同調効果の
生成を図ります」
こういうふうにですね
１人が喋ってる話の切れ目を
自動的に検出して
画面の中では２体のアバターに
割り当ててあげるということをやります
そうすると この人は意識して努力して
何かするんじゃなくて
無意識に 普通に
ディスカッションしてるつもりで
２人の身体を使いこなして
ディスカッションしていることになります
これをですね 先程の
弱い意見の人に使ってもらう訳です
そうすると どうなるかというと
こちら側に見えているのが弱い意見の人に
見えている画面なんですけれども
「自分と違う意見の人が２人いるな」
と思って一生懸命説明する訳ですね
多数派だった人たちには
どう見えているかというと
自分と同じ意見の人が１人いて
自分と意見の違う人が
２人いるように見えます
この状態でディスカッションをすると
どうなるかというと
なんと合意が形成された後に
みんなが納得しているという度合いが
高まるということが分かりました
で 人数の影響とかって
すごい些細なことのように見えるんですが
こういうふうに 結構冷静な議論を
妨げたりする訳です
で「そういうような影響が
人の考え方の癖がいっぱいあるよ」
っていうことを分かったら
それを打ち消す方向に働きかけたり
それをもっとポジティブに使う方向に
働きかけることができるでしょう
こういうことをVRの力をもってすれば
色々なことに使っていけるのではないか
ということを考えています
なので 人をもっと賢くするために
人をもっと人に優しくするために
こういうことを使いたいと思っています
で ここで見てきたように
VRってのは 人の感覚とか
認知の仕組みというのを
普段と違う環境を与えることによって
白日のもとに晒し出してしまう訳です
なので 冒頭で
「皆さん VRって​​何か違う世界に行って
”あぁ 楽しかった！”と言って
帰ってくるだけのものだと
思ってるんじゃないでしょうか？」
という話をしたんですが
実はそうではない
VRの中で体験したことっていうのは
我々の心を変えていて
我々はそれを現実に
持って帰ってきているので
VRで体験したことは
現実の世界を変えていっている訳ですね
なので 我々が食べた物から
できてるように
我々は 情報として
頭の中で処理したものをもってして
我々の心を作り出しているので
我々は 実はVRで体験したことを
かなり現実に持ってきている訳です
ということは
「VRってのは現実を変えている​​」
と言える訳ですね
それで 今日最後の質問にしたいと思います
皆さん どんなふうに 今 自分や現実を
変えたいと思っているでしょうか？
おそらく まあ皆さん
色々なことをお考えだと思います
身の回りの現実とか
自分のことを変えたいなと思う瞬間が
結構あるんじゃないかと思うんですけれど
おそらくVRは それを手助け出来る未来が
すぐにやってくると思います
でも VRで自分を変えてしまうって
結構怖い技術ですよね
「じゃあ 何に使って良くて
何に使っちゃいけないのか？」
っていうことを研究者だけでは
考えることができません
なので「皆さんにVRの技術で
何が出来るのか？」
っていうのを​​知ってもらって
そこから色んな日常に
関係するところで想像してもらって
「あ こういう使い方は私は許せるけど
こういう使い方は許せないな」
というのを想像して頂く
それを我々にフィードバックして頂けると
「こういう研究はしていいとか
こういう研究はしてはいけない」っていうのが
だんだん分かってきます
薬は「用法 用量」ってのがありますよね
で あれはやっぱり長い蓄積のもとで
ここまで使ったら体にいいけれど
これ以上使うと体に悪くなる っていうのが
分かってきている
おそらくVRにも用法とか用量
っていうものが必要だと思っています
そういうものを決めていくためにも
やっぱり皆さんの意見が大事なので
ぜひ皆さんもVRと社会のいい関係を
どうやったら作れるかっていうところを
ちょっと身近な体験から出発して
一緒に考えて頂けると今日は嬉しいです
ありがとうございました
（拍手）